hi everyone
welcome
really excited to share with you
the teachings of bhagavan sri ramana
maharshi
who am i
and
it's
quite short
which is really really nice
and i'm excited because
it'll be something that many of you will
then pick up so the link will be in the
bio
and will
likely profoundly positively influence
your life because
it's a very direct pointing from one of
um
the most clear
spiritual communicators
ever
and
self-inquiry does not require
meditation it does not require sitting
on a cushion it doesn't require
long periods of silence it just requires
you to
[Music]
use your intellect to logically reason
um who you are beyond your costume
so what is
the nature of consciousness what is the
nature of god and how do you just become
aware of the pure awareness
that is shared among
us all
that is that oneness that is god that is
self
and
it requires you to
decline many things including your
thoughts
feelings emotions beliefs
perceptions sensations
your body
your identity your name
and for you to recognize what underlies
everything
so
i would love for you to
also
as we go through this
if there are profound bits
that you would like to go ahead and
pause if you need to the video and write
down those profound bits if you'd like
to also write them in the comments below
that'd be great so we can build little
community of awesome comments down there
and core takeaways this type of stuff
and
for those that are fresh to self-inquiry
this is very very important this is a
core aspect to awakening enlightenment
and
for
those that are
also
even
familiar with it this is a really
helpful direct pointing that's very
short so
one thing that many people
aren't uh aware of is that
ramana maharshi was not talking
um he did not have the inclination to
talk and i frequently also
i have prolonged periods of silence and
it's quite nice because it really allows
you to settle into the capital s self
god
self inquiry non non-yar who am i
so non-yar who am i and self-inquiry
atma-fitchara
the central teaching that the direct
path to liberation is self-inquiry
who am i is persistently pursued the i
thought itself vanishes leaving the
supreme non-dual self alone
false identification of the self with
the phenomena of non-self such as the
body and mind thus ends and there is
illumination
to whom do they arise be extremely
vigilant make the mind stay in its
source
without allowing it to wander away and
get lost in the mazes of thought created
by itself
mind that has gained skill in
concentration self-inquiry becomes
comparatively easy
ceaseless inquiry
that the thoughts are destroyed in the
self-realized in reality in silence
and so
this is where
as long as you have this
mind staying in its source as long as
you have this
i thought that you perpetually dissolve
more and more of the i thought what ends
up remaining is the supreme nondual self
and here's
ramana when he was
21.
so after negating
not this not this that awareness which
alone remains that i am the nature of it
is existence consciousness bliss
sachitananda
when the world which is what is seen has
been removed there will be realization
of the self which is the seer
just as the knowledge of the rope which
is the substratum will not arise unless
the false knowledge of the illusory
serpent goes so the realization of the
self which is the substratum will not be
gained unless the belief that the world
is real is removed
so the world being the s serpent the
snake has to be removed and you have to
recognize yourself as god as rope
you're intoxicated by
the serpent by separation by ego by
conditioning
and there's only one there's only god
there's only self there's only that
oneness
that is all
when the mind which is the cause of all
cognition and of all actions becomes
quiescent
the world will disappear
i had a little bit of that also today
with the world
disappearing
in quiescent mind it's so nice
when the mind comes out of the self the
world appears
the self appears shines the world does
not appear
so mind always exists only in dependence
on something gross
and apart from thoughts there's no
independent entity called the world
just as the spider emits the threat of
the web out of itself and again
withdraws it into itself likewise the
mind projects the world out of itself
and again resolves it into itself
and i love this here ramanus says that
the heart is the mind's origin and so
the eye first arises in the heart and
that is the place of the mind's origin
and so basically if you keep the mind in
the heart if you keep it inwardly turned
that's oneness suchness
when the
generates name form separation this is
the externalization of mind
the thought who am i will destroy all
other thoughts
boom
it will itself in the end get destroyed
there will arise self-realization
to whom has this thought arisen who am i
the mind will go back to its source the
thought that arose will become quiescent
mind will develop the skill to stay in
its source
when it stays in the heart the names and
forms disappear not letting the mind go
out but retaining it in the heart is
what is called inwardness
mind stays in the heart the i which is
the source of all thoughts will go
and the self
which ever exists will shine
one should do without the egoity egoity
of i
if one acts in that way all will appear
as if the nature of shiva god
the thought i is the first thought of
the mind and that is egoity
breath control is only an aid for
rendering the mind quiescent
as thoughts get resolved the mind
becomes one-pointed and strong for such
a mind self-inquiry will become easy
taking of saatvik food in moderate
quantities is the best of all
restrictive rules
helpful in self-inquiry
as the meditation on the self rises
higher and higher the thoughts will get
destroyed
one should persistently hold on to the
meditation on the self
abiding
residual impressions are of two kinds
auspicious is called good and
inauspicious is evil
the mind should not be allowed to wander
towards worldly objects and what
concerns other people
if mind does not leave heart you win the
game of life
both desire and hatred should be
eschewed
all that one gives to others one gives
to oneself if this truth is understood
who will not give to others
as thoughts arise they should be
destroyed then and there in the very
place of their origin through inquiry
contemplation of the self
unintermittently until the self is
gained
what exists in truth is the self alone
the self is that where there is
absolutely no i thought that is called
silence
he who gives himself up to the self that
is god is the most excellent devotee
giving oneself up to god means remaining
constantly in the self without giving
room for the rise of any thoughts other
than that of the self
so stop carrying your luggage not put it
down on the train
as thoughts arise destroying them
utterly without any residue is the very
place of their origin as non-attachment
each one of us should be endowed with
non-attachment to dive with within
oneself and obtain the self pearl
god and the guru are not different
reject altogether the categories that
hide the self the world should be
considered like a dream
in dream the mind takes on another body
all the texts say that in order to gain
liberation one should render the mind
quiescent there will come a time when
one will have to forget all that one has
learned this is
where i'm at right now it's quite
interesting
happiness is very
the very nature of the self there is no
happiness in any object of the world
when the mind goes out its experi it
experiences misery
mind becomes inward turned and enjoys
pure self-happiness
a wise man stays permanently in the
shade
the mind of the one who knows the truth
does not leave brahman
the mind of the ignorant on the contrary
revolves in the world feeling miserable
and for a little time returns to brahman
to experience happiness
what is called the world is only a
thought when the world disappears when
there is no thought the mind experiences
happiness when the world appears it goes
through misery no world no thought no
misery pure happiness pure brahman
remaining quiet is what is called wisdom
insight to remain quiet is to resolve
the mind in the self silence no mind
pure suchness will forever be the
highest teaching
desirelessness is wisdom desirelessness
is refraining from turning the mind
towards any object wisdom means the
appearance of no object
not seeking what is other than the self
is detachment or desirelessness not
leaving the self is wisdom
inquiry consists in retaining the mind
in the self meditation consists in
thinking that oneself is brahman
existence consciousness bliss
inquiring into the nature of oneself
that is in bondage and realizing one's
true nature is liberation
so realizing true nature is liberation
retain the mind itself meditate on
yourself as brahman itself
stay permanently in the shade become
inward turned enjoy that happiness enjoy
not having world not having thought not
having misery
wisdom being desirelessness
happiness being the very nature of self
as soon as the mind goes out it
experiences misery
remember there will be a time when you
have to forget everything you've learned
rendering the mind quiescent is exactly
what yields liberation
in dream the mind takes on another body
so you can even see that logically right
there just like this god taking on a
body
as thoughts arise destroy them utterly
without any residue in the very place
of their origin
is non-attachment
get rid of all of the i thought and then
the self is what remains silence
give yourself to god
stop carrying around your luggage not
coagulation of concepts and ideas
and separation itself and me and my and
i and put it down on the train
mind should not leave the heart
wandering towards worldly objects and
what concerns other people
what exists in truth is the self alone
and as thoughts get resolved the mind
becomes
even easier to do self-inquiry
so the thought i is the first thought of
the mind and that is egoity
and it's the first link independent
origination
your i me my
makes ignorance
mind develops the skill to stay in its
source
keep asking the question
to whom these thoughts arise
have over and over again the destroying
of the thoughts through that inquiry
and then being left with just the self
alone
have the mind stay in the heart
rather than be externalized
have it turned inward
and tap into the heart
being where the mind originates and have
it continuously turned inward on oneness
so as soon as the mind comes out of the
self the world appears
and you negate not this not that
and then awareness alone remains that i
am existence consciousness bliss
the self is the substratum
so
world removed
the mind stain its source
the direct path to liberation is
self-inquiry
thy thought will vanish and leaving the
supreme non-dual self reality
silence
love you
ramana we love you so much
the links in the bio below fam
highly recommend getting this it's a
really simple short read really powerful
for self inquiry
thanks for tuning in infinite love hope
this was
insightful hope this brought you value
so give it a like help the algorithm
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
yet leave a comment below with any of
the powerful quotes from here or your
core takeaways would love to
see some convo happen down there and
share the video with other people that
you feel like this would positively
impact resonate with
and do check this out and potentially
even get a couple copies of it and give
it as gifts to friends because it's
super short and super on point um
and disseminated by one of the greatest
of all time so
all right
infinite love fam thank you so much
may all beings be happy
may all beings be liberated
you